[موسيقى]
وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد تعاني مواقع
التواصل الشهيره من تويتر فيسبوك او لينكد
ان مما يعرف بالحسابات الوهميه او المزيفه
ومع التزايد المستمر لهذه الحسابات اعلن
رايس وتنفيذين لشركه ويتر ماسك اعلن انه
سيفجر ما وصفه بالمفاجاه في اشاره لو
وعوده السابقه بمكافحه هذه الظاهره وكتب
ماسك في تغريده تولد روبوتاته او تولد
نشاطا مزيفا لذلك قد يبدو تويتر اقل نشاطا
ولكن في الحقيقه انتهى النشاط الوهمي من
جهتها اعلنت من الصدمه لانه وخلال سبعه
اشهر اكتشف اكثر من 21 مليون حسابه مزيف
يتم ازالاته من المناصه وبحسب بياناتها
فقد حصل الاختراق بطريقه اليه بالنسبه ل
95% من تلك الحسابات المزيفه عند التسجيله
وفي الفتره عينها زادت بدا مزيف التي ضبطت
بنسبه 28% مقارنه بفتره سته اشهر السابقه
من العام الماضي
هناك هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
الدكتور سعيد صادق استاذه علم الاجتماع
اهلا بيك ومن تكساس الدكتور محمد عبيدات
خبير تكنولوجيا المعلومات والامن السبراني
اهلا بكما ضيوفي الكرام اسم حالي ان ابدا
من وجهه نظر مجتمعيه في الواقع قبل الدخول
في تقنيه هذا الموضوع ولكن همم استاذ همم
دكتور سعيد همم لهم ماسك يحاول ان همم
يعني على الاقل يجعلنا ننتظر شيئا فشيئا
يشوقنا صح التعبير كل مره ينزل جمله ينزل
همم توصيف فلا نعلم ما المفاجاه التي
يتحدث عنها ان كنت فهمت حضرتك ما المفاجاه
هل هي في علاقه بالحسابات المزيفه ما الذي
يقصده بانه مفاجاه كبيره تنتظرنا
شوفي من الصعب جدا انك تتغلبي على هذه
المشكله دي موجوده بقى لها فتره طويله جدا
احنا شوفنا حتى تنظيم داعش كان عنده عشرات
الالوف من الحسابات الوهميه وكان
بيستخدمها فطبعا ده موضوع مش بالسهوله قوي
لنسبه خيالها الناس بتستخدم
اسماء مستعاره ليه او حسابات وهميه ليه
ساعات يا اما عندهم اراء اجتماعيه او
سياسيه متطرفه ومش عايزين همم يدعو هويتهم
الحقيقيه لانهم هيتعرضوا لنوع من العقاب
او الانتقام او القضاء فطبعا ده بالنسبه
لهم افضل شيء يتجنبه همم
بيجاوب على استخدام همم الاسماء المستعاره
لكن بيبقى ماشي في خط معين او المواضيع
اللي بيتصحها هي ثابته مثلا له موقف سياسي
موقف اجتماعي موقف الحادي في منطقه مثلا
ممكن يبقى فيها مشاكل ف يظل احنا عارفين
ان هذا الاسم مثلا الذئب المفترس او
الكتكوت المتوحش احنا عارفين ان هذه
الاسماء طبعا مش حقيقيه لكن عارفين بيتكلم
دايما على المواضيع معينه بعض الاشخاص
بيستخدموا حاجات همم لاسباب اجتماعيه مثلا
علاقه انتهت همم طلاق خائفه مش عارف هي حد
غايبها قريب طليقها انه يتابع حسابها
بتعمل ايه فممكن تعمل حساب جديد وتدي
اسماء مستعاره وتدي فقط للناس اللي هم
قريبين منها هذه الحساب تقدر تضيفهم ويبقى
ايه الصداقه مستمره فطبعا الاسباب عديده
جدا همم
ولكن همم منذ قليل تحدث عن حساب بالشرير
قلت لانه مثلها كذا حسابات ربما دي محاوله
ازعاج لبعض استاذ
كان كتب تغريده منذ ساعات هو وصف تويتر
قال بان تويتر كان يشبه لهذه الشخصيه وهي
شخصيه معروفه بكذبها ومعروفه بانها شخصيه
مسيئه وشريره كانت تغريده منذ ساعات فهو
يحاول على ما يبدو الدكتور محمد عبيدات
ماسك يحاول ان يقدم فكره انه المنقذ لهذه
المنصه وسيقوم بتنظيف هذه المنصه من الكذب
من الغش همم
هل هو قادر تقنيه هو قادر على ذلك تعتقد
شكرا لك تحيه لك ولي المشاهدين ااا
التكنولوجيا موجوده ويمكن استعمالها للحد
من الحسابات المزيفه ولكن حلها بشكل جذري
ليس سهل ستبقى لانه شبكه الانترنت اللي
بنعتمد عليها كلياتنا هي غير امينه هي
اسستغرب
واقول جسدا فجاه لقيت حالها
تستضيف
تستمر زباين ما كانت تتوقعها
فطبعا يمكن تقليل
فعاليتها ولكن لا يمكن حلها بشكل جيد
ستبقى هناك تكنولوجيات كثيره يمكن
استعمالها مثل التكنولوجيا
التعلم العميد ابو الديب اليمني او التعلم
الاهالي ماشي
تكنولوجيات الذكاء الصناعي يمكن استعمالها
لهذا الامر كما يمكن
البيولوجيه للشخص لان كل انسان في مزايا
بيولوجيه مثل
الشبكيه التضاريس الشبكيه تضاريس القزحيه
الشكل الوجه
الفنجر البرنس بصمات الاصابع وغيرها يمكن
استعمالها للتحقق من الاشخاص انهم حقيقيين
ولا لا التحقق من البريد الالكتروني ورقم
الهاتف والبروفايل نفسه اللي بيكون فيه
صوره طبعا اذا مثلا حط لك واحد صوره
بيوتفل
انها تكون لامراه وهانسم لرجل فهذا يعطيك
اشاره حمراء انه هاي الصوره مزيفه وصاحبها
غير حقيقي
طبعا هناك همم تكنولوجيا مثلا همم
على الذكاء الصناعي اللي بتقدر تكشف الصور
المزيفه من الصور الحقيقيه اااه
تعاني من
المزيفه هي كذلك على فكره الحسابات اللي
مزيفه طالت كل المنصات فيسبوك تويتر
انستغرام
همم وكاننا دكتور سعيد صار البعض يعيش
حقيقه ويعيش كذلك في عالم موازي همم لماذا
يحتاج البعض الى فرض ارائه لا نتحدث فقط
عن الاراضي الاراء المتطرفه هناك البعض
الذي يسيء او يمدح ولكن من خلال حساب مزيف
لماذا يضطر البعض ذلك
مثلا عايز ينتقم او عنده احد بيكرهه فهو
لو طلع بهويته الحقيقيه هيتم عقابه فهنا
يبقى افضل له نعمل حساب مزيف بيعمل ايه
الاعداد يعني الاعداد صارت الاعداد هائله
وكان المجتمعات تشكي من شيء ماء له تكون
حاضره بكل همم هذه الكميه من خلال حسابات
مزيفه
السوشيال ميديا عباره عن مراه للمجتمع
وادت فرصه لاي شخص عنده مشاكل اييي انه
يستخدمها ويبقى هو رئيس تحرير وهو رئيس
القناه وهو كل حاجه يعني ده شيء واضح قوي
في احد الابلكيشانات المشهوره قوي
كلابهاوس يمتلئ ايضا بجميع انواع الشخصيات
اللي يمكن حتى بعضهم ارهابيين وبعضهم
مجرمين وبعضهم هربانين من العداله وبيحطوا
اسماء مستعاره وبيتحدث
ههه وفيما بعد همم هناك ساختم باختصار
شديد معك الدكتور دقيقه
الكريم اسمحي لي اضيفي شيء اذا ممكن من
وراء هذه حسابات المزيفه
الحصول على اكبر عدد من البريد الالكتروني
لبيعها للت
سويق وسرقه الهويه الشخصيه للاشخاص طبعا
الامير كده بتسرق السوشل سكيورتي رقم
الضمان الاجتماعي ممكن تاخذ لون عليه قرض
اذا برمجيات وسلبيات الهاردوير السوفت وير
لحاسوب الشخص المستلم همم كذلك همم عندما
ينتقل هذا الاتصال الجديد للتواصل مع شخص
ما كنت به قبل قليل
لهذا الشخص ان يرى انك متصل بالشخص الذي
بقيه ولا النقاش بقيه الوقت ادركنا في
حلقه اخرى من القاهره دكتور سعيد صادق
استاذ عالم الاجتماع دكتور محمد عبيدات
خبيره التكنولوجيا المعلومات والامن
والسلام عليكم